okay perfect first of all you look
amazing tonight how are you feeling
thank you i'm excited yeah do you have
nerves are you feeling good about the
performance i don't really get nervous i
just get really really excited and the
only thing i freak out about is like
maybe i'll forget the words okay yeah
maybe you'll freak out if you were to
run into avril lavigne we know that she
is here tonight
would you freak out yeah i would keep my
cool i'm trying to be professional that
i'd freak out a little bit inside what
has everland her music meant to you as a
young artist yeah i mean when i was
younger i just felt like she was the
canadian music representation for me
like feeling like i grew up in a small
town in canada so i was constantly like
nobody does anything but avril lavigne
was always like the canadian artist and
i was like i can do this just like her
oh my god you know it's so amazing just
hearing the impact that she's had on
everybody tonight like it's pretty wild
yeah um okay shawn mendes also here
tonight if you could describe him in one
word what would it be oh um zen
so i met sean we're like sort of
friends-ish he's very zen yeah loves his
like essential oils wants to like
be involved with plants yeah very zen
it's probably really important
especially in this industry with so much
going on that's awesome great he's got
his like meditation down to a t i think
yeah okay very cool okay who else are
you excited to see tonight oh um jessia
love her
yeah i love her um my boyfriend's
favorite artist is like toby
so we can't wait to see him there's so
many people here yeah
seema liu is hosting tonight if you had
a superpower what would it be
um being able to fly on a broomstick
like harry potter
that is my favorite answer of the night
being a slytherin right here
i'm a gryffindor but it's okay we can
still be friends
yes we can amazing so nice talking to
you